ja maximilian afra die isd 29 absolut
verzweifelt deprimiert und so frustriert
dass sie jetzt ihren job als
krankenschwester nach sieben jahren hin
schmeißt warum sie ihren traum vom
menschen retten aufgegeben hat es
erzählt sie uns jetzt am besten gleich
selbst frau schaffrath schön dass sie
dabei sind ja meine erste frage direkt
sieben jahre haben sie diesen beruf
jetzt gemacht wir alle wissen der ist
super super anstrengend aber warum haben
die jetzt gesagt nein mir reicht's
also mir ist es einfach als coo
zukunftsperspektive emotional und
körperlich dauerhaft einfach zu belasten
es ist immer der der schichtdienst die
ständigen wechsel zehn bis zwölf tage am
stück und die teils menschlichen
extremfälle die man nicht immer in der
klinik lassen kann sondern ihnen
manchmal auch mit nach hause nimmt und
sie haben darüber ein buch geschrieben
ich habe auch so ein bisschen rein lesen
können was waren denn für sie die
schlimmsten erfahrungen aus ihrer
ausbildungszeit beziehungsweise in
diesem gesamten sieben jahren also
innerhalb meiner ausbildung gleich in
den ersten praktischen einsatz das war
eine krebsstation und ich war acht
wochen dort und da sind über zehn
menschen gestorben
ich bin oft weinend nach hause gegangen
und keiner der examinierten kolleginnen
hatte zeit mit mir darüber zu sprechen
ich denke sie hätten es vielleicht gerne
getan aber sie waren es so und einem
immensen zeitdruck dass sie einfach
nicht mit mir sprechen konnten und das
ist eins von vielen erlebnissen wo ich
eben denke so kann diese ausbildung
nicht sein weil so bekommen wir einfach
keinen nachwuchs ja dann hat uns ganz
kurz ein
wenn sie sagen sie sind oft weinend nach
hause gegangen und niemand hatte zahlt
mit ihm zu sprechen sie haben sie das
dann alles verarbeitet also haben sie
sich jemand anderen gesucht oder haben
sie das mit sich ausgemacht wie war das
ich habe tatsächlich ich hatte einen
guten freund mit dem habe ich häufig
telefoniert
ich habe auch mal die eltern angerufen
ich habe nach diesem einsatz auf der
krebsstation in unserer pflegeschule um
ein gespräch gebeten bei einer lehrerin
das habe ich dann tatsächlich auch
bekommen aber dass das alles konnte
nicht setzen dass die direkt betroffenen
kollegen die auch wussten worum es geht
das die nicht mit mir ansprechen können
wenn man das jetzt so hört dann höre ich
vor allem heraus dass eine bessere
bezahlung klar wer die fällig aber die
würde jetzt nicht das problem lösen
sondern sie brauchen einfach mehr leute
mehr zeit was ist das konkret ja also da
haben sie völlig recht es ist nicht nur
eine bessere bezahlung die drückt zwar
eine wertschätzung aus aber
grundsätzlich sind die
arbeitsbedingungen und die müssen schon
in der ausbildung einfach besser werden
weil es sind genug motivierte junge
menschen da die das anfangen wollen aber
dadurch dass die bedingungen so
furchtbar sind dann weiß ich man muss es
leider so sagen innerhalb der ausbildung
schmeißen halt wirklich sehr viele
varianten schon hin
wir ziehen jetzt nach sieben jahren die
schlusslinie den schlussstrich es ist ja
schon sehr gewagt also immerhin in der
zeit sind viele froh arbeiten zu können
gut krankenschwester die sind am limit
haben sie schon pläne für danach haben
sie schon neuen job oder wollen sie sich
komplett neu orientieren
also ich denke ich werde nicht komplett
neu orientieren aber so richtig genau
weiß ich das ehrlich gesagt noch nicht
nein dann vielen dank frau schaffrath
dass sie uns ihre geschichte erzählt
haben ich danke ihnen ja gerne mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren